Here’s a question for all of you, what brand
is your mobile phone?
I guess many of you will answer Apple, Samsung
or Huawei.
How do I know?
Well no, I’m not psychic or anything like
that.
I just know because year after year these
three companies have lead sales in the global
mobile phone market.
Together they sell approximately half of all
smartphones in the world.
Although, due to recent events, things could
change a lot.
The point is, folks, that we’re talking
about a huge market.
It’s estimated that in 2018 the number of
smartphone users reached the staggering figure
of 3 billion people.
China tops the list of most users worldwide,
almost 780 million Chinese use a smartphone
every day.
And not only that.
China has also become a key player in the
industry.
For example, it’s the country of origin
of some of the largest smartphone manufacturers
in the world.
We’re talking about companies like Huawei
and ZTE.
So, do you know where in China these devices
are manufactured?
Yes, in the city of Shenzhen, better known
as China’s Silicon Valley.
We’ve already told you about this incredible
place in several videos.
And we have also told you how in just 40 years,
Shenzhen has gone from being a small fishing
town to becoming a megacity that specializes
in advanced technology.
It’s one of the fastest growing places on
the planet.
In case, if you haven’t seen them, I’ll
leave a link to several related videos in
the description.
And, it isn’t just Chinese companies like
Huawei or ZTE, even Apple and Samsung work
with a lot of suppliers in this city.
This means that practically all of us are,
in one way or another, dependent on Shenzhen.
We use this city’s products constantly,
every day 24/7.
In other words, we all have a little bit of
Shenzhen in our hands!
Now, how exactly did this enormous transformation
take place?
Is it a unique case in the world?
And the most important question, what on earth
has Shenzhen to do with Honduras, one of the
poorest countries in the Americas, if not
the world?
Listen up
(THE SEED OF CHANGE)
We told you here on VISUALPOLITIK, at the
beginning of the 1980s, the then Chinese president,
Deng Xiaoping created a “Special Economic
Zone” on the border with Hong Kong, in Shenzhen.
It was the first of many areas that would
later spread throughout China.
Now, just a moment, many of you may be thinking:
what exactly is a Special Economic Zone?
Well, folks, a Special Economic Zone is basically
a defined geographical area within a country
where the rules for doing business are different,
usually much less restrictive, than in the
rest of the country.
These zones, folks, were designed as a way
to boost trade and investment.
They have clear geographical limits; different
rules and regulations; and their own administrative
system.
In short, we’re talking about territories
designed to target business, production and
investment.
So in China’s case, these places became
capitalist havens within a completely socialist
model.
And, do you know what?
They were a huge success.
The opening of these economic zones attracted
a huge amount of investment, of both Chinese
and foreign capital.
All this investment attracted thousands of
immigrants and drove the construction of factories
and homes.
By the mid-1990s, Shenzhen already had three
million inhabitants and an extraordinarily
dynamic economy.
The process continues to this day.
Shenzhen currently has 12 million residents,
which rises to 15 million during the summer
and fall season when factories work exhaustively
to meet the demand for electronic gifts for
Christmas.
Santa Claus, folks, can’t forget all the
smartphones, drones and latest generation
gadgets that are sold during the Holiday Season
as if there were no tomorrow.
However, China hasn’t been the only country
to bet on this model.
Another example can be found in the United
Arab Emirates, especially in the Emirate of
Dubai.
If you’re a fan of this channel, you would
have heard us talking about this in other
videos.
For example, there’s Jebel Ali or Dubai’s
Financial Center.
The latter not only has its own regulations,
but also its own courts.
It also includes reduced bureaucracy, fewer
taxes, a lot of legal security and simple
procedures to do business.
What more could you want?
Well, the fact is that the strategy to diversify
the UAE economy beyond oil was based fundamentally
on these Special Economic Zones, of which
there are currently more than 45 throughout
the country.
The result?
The Emirates have had the highest economic
growth in the entire region since 1980.
During this time, its GDP has multiplied by
no less than ten.
Now, just a second.
Does this mean that opening Special Economic
Zones is a recipe for success?
Well, sadly that doesn’t seem to be the
case.
For a Special Economic Zone to really work,
it needs to meet certain requirements:
It needs to manage itself with complete autonomy;
have good infrastructure; there needs to be
a lot of legal security; a lot of economic
freedom; low taxes, little bureaucracy and
enough land to expand.
So far, we have seen two success stories:
China and the UAE.
Now, can we find a case where this strategy
has failed?
Of course.
In a way, India has historically been an example
not to follow.
Allow me to explain.
India established its first Special Economic
Zones back in the 1960s, much earlier than
China.
In fact, it could be considered a pioneer
in the strategy.
However, in spite of its head start, by the
year 2000 there were barely seven zones operating
throughout the country, with much, much more
modest results than those of the Chinese example.
Why?
Well, folks, these areas didn’t manage to
eliminate bureaucracy, they didn’t work
autonomously, they had limited space and operated
with too many restrictions.
Basically, instead of Special Economic Zones,
they were shelled areas.
That’s one of the reasons China has grown
much more than India in recent decades.
Now, just a second.
If you’ve made it this far you’re probably
thinking: Simon, what on earth does all this
have to do with Honduras?
Well... listen up.
(THE HONDURAN EXPERIMENT, REALITY OR FICTION?)
Folks, Special Economic Zones are very popular
in the world of international trade.
Since the 1980s, they’ve sprouted up like
weeds.
In 1986, the International Labor Organization
reported 176 areas in 47 countries, and in
2006 there were already more than 3,500 in
130 countries.
Currently in Latin America, it is estimated
that there are more than 300 Special Economic
Zones.
More than half of these are in Central America.
Of course, as you can imagine, with much more
restrictive conditions than in China’s case.
You know, Latin governments love to control
everything... or at least they try to.
However, folks, there is a country that has
put a plan on the table to change this situation.
That country is Honduras.
Honduras is one of the poorest countries in
the entire region.
A country where the vast majority of the population
lives in poverty, which has enormous rates
of violence and where every year tens and
tens of thousands of people try to escape
in search of a better life, usually to the
United States.
‘I have to try’: New migrant caravan leaves
Honduras and heads for the United States.Washington
Post)
Violence and gangs obscure life in Honduras,
America Economía)
Well folks...
In recent years Honduras has presented an
ingenious plan to try to change this situation.
A plan in which the American economist Paul
Romer, winner of the Nobel Prize in Economics
of 2018, has played a prominent role.
The strategy consists of creating “Zones
of Employment and Economic Development”
throughout the country.
Now, what exactly are the ZEEDs?
Well, folks, along the same lines that we
talked about and given that things don’t
work in Honduras, ZEEDs are a kind of experiment
aimed at jump-starting economic activity so
it can grow from scratch in some areas of
the country.
That is, ZEEDs will be areas in the Honduran
national territory that will have special
regulations and their own institutions to
guarantee security – both physical and legal
– and more ease to do business.
As everything would start from scratch, it
wouldn’t be necessary to change the entire
national system, which seems impossible due
to all the existing interests.
The idea is that these ZEEDs will attract
a lot of investment and create many jobs,
so that they can create a change in the rest
of the country.
As happened with China’s Special Economic
Zones.
The ZEEDs will have their own legal personality,
will be administered autonomously and are
authorized to establish their own policies
and regulations.
And not only that.
They will also have their own police, their
own independent courts and operate under the
tradition of Anglo-Saxon law, known as “common
law”.
Additionally, these areas’ land will be
the property of the state, but its administration
will be borne by the ZEEDs themselves, which
will define how that land can be accessed
or developed.
All in a competitive framework, so that companies
and investors can have the land they need
for their projects without having to face
heavy urban regulations that could slow development.
That way, each special zone can specialize
in different activities or be organized in
different ways to not only compete with the
rest of the world but also to compete with
each other, something that would force its
administrators to copy and improve the best
existing policies to attract investment, attract
talent and ultimately boost the country’s
development.
Smart right?
We can imagine financial centers, logistics
centers, special tourist areas and even autonomous
cities.
Wait, autonomous cities?
Yes, you heard that right: why limit these
special zones only to companies?
Why not try to build coexistence models that
can work better than the mess that currently
exists in Honduras?
These are known as “Free cities”, something
we’ll be talking about extensively here
on VisualPolitik.
So, don’t forget to subscribe and click
the bell to keep up with all our new videos.
But just a second before you start ringing
the bells.
Folks, this may sound like a very, very attractive
project, but isn’t it surprising that it’s
actually the Honduran political elite who’s
leading this process?
Isn’t that suspicious?
Honduran President’s Brother, Arrested in
Miami, Is Charged With Drug Trafficking.
New York Times)
Well, that’s actually what Paul Romer himself
thinks.
He decided to distance himself from the project.
Why?
Well, because he thinks that the Honduran
elite doesn’t really want to promote competition
and investment, they want to have a territory
that will only benefit them.
They have passed a new law that crosses my
bright red line.
It removes all possibility of electoral accountability
for the people who run the zone.
This was not in the law that I supported.
[...]
I can’t tell if what we are watching is
a farce or a tragedy.
It could end up as farce because I can’t
imagine a thoughtful investor would go in
and invest under these circumstances, in a
place controlled by a crony aristocracy.
Paul Romer)
And he isn’t the only doubter.
This project’s evolution has raised many
doubts, the ZEEDs could even end up simply
being an instrument so that the oligarchs
as always can take over more sections of the
country and play with them at whim.
The lack of transparency and the country’s
social conflicts don’t seem to reflect the
image of ​​a government that seeks to
promote development.
That’s why the initial buzz has been replaced
by disenchantment and suspicion.
Basically, we’re presented with a fantastic
idea, and possibly a terrible execution.
In any case, the ZEEDs are projected to start
at the end of 2019.
If they manage to consolidate them and move
forward respecting the spirit of freedom,
competition and equality of opportunities
with which the Special Economic Zones were
born, we could be facing a total change of
course for Honduras.
But, at this point, it’s hard to be optimistic
about this.
In short, the question is, is Honduras really
serious about creating a model of fully autonomous
ZEEDs without political interference?
Will Honduras become Central America’s Shenzhen
or will it become another failed case like
India?
Whatever the result, we’ll be watching the
progress here, on VisualPolitik.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe for brand new videos.
Don’t forget to check out our friends at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the voiceover in this episode.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.